this is a production of cornell
university
yeah so see uh we start the the third
episode here of our cornell turf show
fastest 30 minutes in turf
uh thanks everyone for stopping by uh
for our live attendees just a quick poll
on on where you guys are located um it
looks like everybody
on in the live audience here is from the
northeast so uh
good for us to know there we'll get that
out of the way um as always we'll start
with uh
with frank um first thing with frank
frank's always got some some cool stuff
uh you know a little tidbit from social
media
um kicks us off on a light note uh what
do you got here frank
all right carl thanks so so uh i have to
tell you
golf is underway um you know people are
itching
i know i work with a degenerate golfer
here on a regular basis and i know he's
chomping at the bit to get out there and
start playing
uh well aware of all the courses opening
within a reachable drivable radius he
can go
whacking it around and of course you
know we're all expecting this
uh this spring and you know makes you
wonder do we need to begin to adapt our
golf courses to accommodate
this kind of demand right we've long
waited for golf courses to get
use and now we're lamenting uh the use
that we're getting but
one of the things that i found inspiring
this week was
was the young people uh with the pet
with the bags on their back
you know exercising as much as uh
playing this game of golf
and i also found a neat little piece of
data here again visualizing data you
know one
as we talk about using data the ability
to visualize it
for people is going to be so important
and
you know look where people play golf you
know if you see where people play golf
and and uh you'll see you know this is
where
a lot of the interest in golf is and and
so right
before we get to you carl and uh and the
bmp tip
i i came across this gem you know when
we talk about communicating with golfers
you know i absolutely absolutely love
this particular graphic that somebody
tweeted or put out there somewhere
uh how you can explain uh golf
forecasting
to the average golfer so carl with that
let's go
let me advance the slide and it's your
turn for the uh bmp minute
yeah so again uh talking about our erp
project with the folks at rit
uh we came up with this infographic
poster each week we're just gonna
pull a quick tip off that poster and
today's tip you know relates to our
guest rich buckley
um and uh you know it's it's just about
when we're applying pesticides thinking
about when we're applying them
and uh focusing on hey when the pressure
is high we can apply then
but especially in the early spring
season we'll talk about that today
late fall season if you don't have
pressure you know don't apply don't go
when the pressure is low
and there's actually some cool data i
was uh searching around on twitter the
other day and found some data
on this next slide here frank um from uh
from a grad student at rutgers who
actually will be presenting today at the
rutgers turf grass symposium um but it's
it's just a quick graph here of the
the dollar spot index smith current's
dollar spot index
and when they noted disease on untreated
bots and as you can see
uh the red line here is the risk index
so when you see spikes in that you see a
slight lag maybe one
two days and there goes the increase in
dollar spot
and and we're talking about uh
responsible pesticide use only
applying when you need to uh this is
what we're talking about looking at
these models
uh letting them guide your decision
making um
you know that's that's what we're uh
we're focusing in on and that's our bmp
tip of the day
excellent carl we're going to get back
to this in a minute don't you worry
all right let's get through the weather
here and um
using our base 50 growing degree days we
typically start accumulating on march
15th
uh you can see that it's starting to
happen a little bit at very low levels
down where riches in the in
in the metropolitan new york area
certainly in in the delmarva it's well
underway into the 30s
and but the forecast immediately uh
through the rest of this week into the
weekend uh is calling for not very many
accumulated growing degree days so
at base 50. so i i wouldn't expect the
growing season
to advance um i'll just make a note
that uh there are some dry areas that
are continuing
uh throughout the northeast at least
based on the last drought monitor we'll
see as it comes out
um uh and this coming week uh this
thursday
probably well today honestly the new map
will probably be out
all right so what kind of rainfall are
we expecting in the coming week it looks
pretty good for a solid shot of rainfall
through
uh from uh eastern ohio through central
pa
all the way cover in new jersey where
really where rich is sitting we're
expecting a pretty heavy dose and
again rich we were laughing last week
about how you absolutely got buried
in rainfall when a lot of us were
talking about dry weather now
looking at the forecast moving forward
this is the week looking out the noaa
forecast week looking out 23rd through
the 29th
on the left is the precip and looks like
might be above normal in the middle of
the country
uh much of the north some of the
northeast you'll see the gradient there
out in western new york
some above normal some normal and then
some below normal
now when it comes to temperatures across
the board next week they're expecting to
warm up now art originally pre uh you
know said
hey we're going to be cooler and it
looks like we're going to be cooler a
little bit this coming week
now what are we starting to see uh i
have a slack channel i make we maintain
with
the variety of projects we work on and
here was a couple from our
golf slack channel this year already uh
on the left from carl on the right from
josh fontaine running a golf
course in in the capital district former
technician here
uh you can see some really ripe looking
snow mold you know i can see
rich buckley already is getting excited
with all this pathology going on out
there
but again you know just to remind people
this is the fourth hole at the rtj
from a couple of years ago where dave
hicks you know stops spraying
right sprays the fairway but but doesn't
spray in the rough and you see
this is one of the reasons it's very
easy to see why we use pesticides
now uh you know we're not going to pass
judgment you know about recovery and
stuff like that but certainly
you don't want this stuff happening too
much on your putting surfaces
uh your fairways maybe like in this case
hopefully recovery will occur
but you'll also notice some mitigating
factors right you've got some shade
you can see some poor drainage here
where you see some standing water
uh on the area right snow molds always
going to be worse
in these low-lying shaded areas even
without
leafing out these trees or causing some
pretty significant shade problems
all right so let's talk about the coming
spring as it goes to soil temperature
because in the golf business
we use soil temperature a lot to trigger
early season
pesticide applications which got my
colleague
carl scamenti uh worked up when he saw
some
uh email alerts coming out about hey
you know we're promoting early season
pesticide use so
um you know we looked at the
temperatures and and when we look at our
triggers
uh most of our triggers are 55 65
for our spring treatments you don't see
a lot of
soil temperatures that are earlier than
that at the two inch step
then just a reminder you know you're
talking about
still in the mid 30s upper 30s low 40s
throughout much of the region
particularly to the southern part of the
region i mean you've got to get down
you know past into delmarva to start to
get something north of the mid 40s
no surprise there so of course you're
pretty early
for your summer patch and fairy ring
applications
uh john ingrassado was lit us with us
last spring
and talked quite a bit about uh summer
patch and take all patch
where he looked at cultivation and
manganese treatments
on summer patching kentucky bluegrass
but
one of the things we know about take all
patch different than
summer patch and fairy ring all of these
are root based pathogens
all of these things are harder to
control in foliar pathogens
these are much more complex not only
because of the way they behave in the
soil
but the things that we apply to control
these things
act as drenches right so you want to
drench your fungicide down into the soil
so it can be taken up by the plant
because all of these fungicides
only move up there's only one that moves
up and down that's the
phosphate pythium uh alliet but
in general they all move up and so you
know when you're treating root diseases
you want to get soil temperature right
because these things break down
and you want the treatment to occur near
when the infection might occur so you
get maximum efficacy about the
around the product because you're going
to need control for a bunch of months
now take all patches one that in fact
targeting that treatment in the fall
seems to be better uh than spring
treatments now again this would be a
bigger issue
maybe on some warm season grasses where
this is becoming a hellacious problem
down there
and uh especially on ultra dwarf uh
bermuda grass greens
but also um on our bent grass surfaces
up north now
just to get carl going on this and rich
welcome to set you up a little bit
brother
you know i poked around because i'm old
enough to remember and i know you are
too
when uh you know the early season
applications for dollar spot came around
and the argument was
that if you applied early you
could delay infection to the point
where it might save you some fungicide
applications for a foliar disease like
dollar spot for example
and so you know i poked around and i
knew kaminsky
when he was at connecticut saw a
positive result to this
i know derek settle in the midwest
resulted uh
reported a positive result to this when
he was with the cdga
and i know paul koch also in this slide
reported a positive thing that they
could delay
that early they could delay the
time when carl was showing all that risk
they could delay
uh the need for that but that's not
universal
for all diseases when it comes to spring
applications so
rich listen welcome to the program uh
and uh for those of you listening on
podcast right you're
you're not able to see some of the
things so we hope you can join us live
and look at us sometime or
watching the video here but rich uh
let's start out with
what do you know and what do you hear
about
early season treatments at this stage
for some of these diseases to maybe
delay
application later because that seems to
me to be the most sketchy
of these recommendations so let's start
there
all right well i'm just trying to make
myself show up
on my my video but what the hell don't
worry about it
i'll talk anyway um there i'd searched a
little bit too
and most of the research about uh the
early season dollar spot applications
um came out in like the mid-2000s 2007
2008 there's a bunch of research there
um
and the idea here is if you
can suppress the dollar spot pathogen
which will be
metabolically active between about 40
and 50 degrees
you can reduce the amount of inoculum
and push the disease off
for a while in the spring all well and
good
um the research if i and if i can
represent
james hemkling a little bit uh here
james found that
it it didn't make a difference you know
in his work the app the
initial application timing and he used a
bunch of different parameters for that
um it didn't matter and that that uh
uh after talking to him and watching him
uh do the work for a
couple years my uh uh i
my my impression is you're not gonna get
any additional advantage
if you apply a material before about
mid-may
and following the model the smith kearns
model may be the best
choice because it seemed to indicate
uh uh an increased risk at about this
mid-may time period for at least at
rutgers and i got to tell you rich the
thing that comes to mind for me when
we're talking like this
is you know even since the mid 2000s
i think the pressure in the fall for
dollar spot
continues to be greater and greater
every year and that's why i'm wondering
if maybe these things might have made
sense in certain
certain situations with really
susceptible
varieties under ideal conditions
during the season and maybe now
we should be rethinking this that we've
got models
that allow us to predict better uh
that might also result in reductions
based on what you're saying hemplings
showing
yeah well there's in his work the the
most significant factor was the cultivar
right so the new you know i i'm from
rutgers so it's my job to sell grassy
but but uh you know i i've over the
years have come i
have been more and more convinced that
genetics is everything for the for this
stuff
you know and the new improved grasses
for a number of diseases are good now
now
that being said yeah we we do see more
disease
dollar spot in the fall and uh
i think the modeling is is a great way
of reducing uh
you know the the the old degree day
models for dollar spot are inconsistent
you know we could talk about all the
different types of models out there
since the 80s but the one that shows
like it
looks like it is consistently uh
accurate is the smith kearns model
and if you just follow the model you
know i think you're going to save
treatments and if you have better
cultivars you're going to save even more
treatments
all right so let me bug you uh what i
know is coming especially as the traffic
comes and maybe growth isn't happening
we're starting to mow and roll and prep
the surfaces early
uh we usually get a flare up and people
talk about early season anthracnose you
want to take a minute and talk about
early season anthracnose on the putting
greens
and what you've learned about and taught
us about with
how some of this might be stuff carrying
over i i think it carries over i mean
the the uh there's they're polite about
it in the in the literature
talking about spring basal infections
but we we had a conversation
years ago about what's the low
temperature threshold for the fungus
and it doesn't appear one there's not a
whole lot of data and two it doesn't
appear like it grows
below maybe 60 degrees so
if you have anthracnose carrying over
now you know it's very likely
something from last season and we've
built up enough inoculum
from flareups last year to carry into
the spring
you know uh um no treat treat or just
try to grow out of it
i try to grow out of it i you know i i
i'm also convinced now that that golf
guys use too many fungicides i've looked
at spray sheets for 30 years
and i'm like man these guys are out of
their minds and i don't want to make any
enemies here but
but uh it's okay nobody's listening and
nobody's watching for now
until they hear about what we're talking
about then we'll have everybody
listening
it's uh uh i i i really think that if
you can grow it out
that you should you should go that way
um you're not going to recover the
plants that are infected they're they're
dead and go anyway and and uh and we
like to
front load nitrogen into the system you
know uh uh
uh you know uh instead of uh
of using a tenth of a pound or something
you know go point three point three
point three with your seed head
suppression or something
and then you got a pound going in and
and we're talking about
annual bluegrass here too and uh then
then you
you have a little reserve it's like
eating a big bowl of oatmeal before i go
bike ride that's right
that's right well listen now of course i
showed some images and everybody you
know no one needs an image
uh particularly as with the amount of
snow cover you got
uh did you get a lot of snow mold
samples you know we've been curious
about this we'll probably start up the
conference call next week
where we'll have a little more intimate
conversations about this but
what are you getting in the lab from the
snow mold front whether it's pink or
gray
we we i've seen some of both i've seen
some of both
um not a ton i think everyone's pretty
aware with the snow cover
that what they've got you know it's an
easier i uh diagnosis
uh uh but i've had a bunch of people
sending me pictures of
squarosha you know so we have we had
gray for the first time here since 2015.
you know right outside my window here i
could find it you know i had about
five weeks of snow cover you know so so
uh uh
you know i would expect with gray
you can recover relative you know rake
it and
fertilize and just move on with the pink
you know microdocium will be active up
until about june
so you may think about doing something
for that
yeah well we don't live like in the
pacific northwest
like clint maddox alec and and brian up
there in the pacific northwest at oregon
state
where it's 10 11 months of pink snow
mold pressure uh
on your annual bluegrass along the coast
so it is important for people to
understand
this is uh i think there is also good uh
resistance in the bank grasses
uh for some of the pink snow molds and
also
rich uh rolling plays a part uh i think
in some pink snowmobile control
so i'm wondering um you know
first i'm wondering about recovery and
you said gray snow mold
probably it wasn't bad enough where it's
dead
it'll probably if you scratch it up and
get some of that rutgers seed on it
it'll be perfectly fine yeah
yeah i think that yeah well rolling
and you know moisture management if you
can
in the spring um matters uh
you know the those folks in
in oregon are using iron sulfate too you
know
um maybe a little iron you know they
it looks like there's a little
phytotoxicity there um
but uh uh a little nitrogen
mitigates that issue so so uh you know i
think there's there's
options and i think the big thing is now
at least on the top you know tops
i don't know how much people are growing
yet i haven't really heard
people saying that they're you know
growing like the dickens yet
um but if they are uh that's probably
good
based on the traffic now where the soil
is still
cool rich uh the roots you know are
having a ball here
uh and what we tried to do i tried to do
in the intro
is to say okay these things are
complicated with regard to root
pathogens as we
think about below the soil um
can you be too early with these
fungicide applications why
is it so important you know we hear from
the pre-emergent crabgrass guys hey
let's just get it down we got to get it
down
why isn't it oh why do we want to
put that application so tied to soil
temperature if we put it on
won't it still be there in a week or two
uh
yeah um but but that that's a good
question
um if i i'll go back to dr latin's book
from 2011.
and dr latin would suggest that the
fungicides aren't effective unless the
fungi are biologically active if they're
metabolizing and starting to grow and we
know from
lab lab work the the temperature
parameters
that these root pathogens like
magnifortheopsis summer patch
will grow at so we if we if we can get
to
that window you know uh you're going to
get better control you're going to get
the
growth regulator type because that's
what these these materials are fungal
growth regulators
yeah you're going to get you're going to
get a a a good uptake
and a good uh response by the fungus
now the other thing that dr latin's book
would suggest
is that you know these materials
disappear from the system pretty quickly
right and so you know you put it down
two weeks ahead of time that year's oxy
strobin's long gone
and the fungus hadn't had a chance to
get a good drink of it yet
you know so so you we we're really need
to get into that that
the timings is essential really for
these diseases
and i think you know what's really
important and it's not well known you
know paul koch got himself
to be the expert in you know timing of
snow mold applications and how they
break down and wear out right
and and but i got to tell you you know
it's amazing and we know how growth
regulators work right because we can
measure clippings
but i often wonder why we haven't
done some of this metabolism work of
these fungicides that we're applying
to not just encounter the organism when
it's feeding but to make sure it's in
the plant providing some protection
assuming that it's just going to sit
there for
weeks and weeks do have you ever is does
latin's book
elaborate on the how the plant breaks it
down because obviously it breaks down in
the soil to a certain extent
but it's also getting into the plant has
did latin
uh and boy do i love rick latin we
actually just chatted with one of his
former grad students john daniels our
usga
uh northeast rep on this topic uh
with with dr latin so what is he does he
say anything about how the plant
metabolizes these things
i think that there's a there's a little
bit uh about it and i
i'm thinking of a graphic where he has
uh you know
bio assays where he's showing
the disease at different weekly
intervals
you know so so you know it's it's not
just measuring the soil
or the measuring the concentration but
he has disease work with it you know
uh so so that's some indication but i i
you know there there's probably it's
probably a right
uh for some for some research well
i mean here's the thing that's
fascinating to me
you know year in year out um we owe
i think especially for you in the
diagnostic world
it becomes a not if but when
the summer patch samples will begin to
come in and
i would say working with you all these
years that that's somewhat
tied often times to heat stress and
drought stress or
sometimes saturation stress where then
you know they're saturated because they
don't drain
and then you know the summer patch is
competing with the pythium to determine
which is actually gonna
you know kill the plant so what i'm
wondering about is have you seen a
pattern over the last several years
uh in our summer patch problems that we
get every year
that might be related to our lack of
getting this treatment right in the
spring or
are we basically saying listen we got so
much summer patch pressure
you could spray three drenches and it's
not gonna work
where are you at on explaining this to
us well there's there's two things and i
think there's a little of both here you
know
one um timing matters
you know and so you have to execute well
uh when you when you do this and
and and you may have to
use the summer patch program
outside of your normal program you know
so execution
rates product choice
timing the dilution rate you know
getting it into the root zone all that
has to
has to go right right then you know i
see guys that break through
and a lot of times it's breaking through
on really high-end golf courses growing
po
under extraordinary stresses
you know mowing heights at 10th or below
and you know
you know hard as a rock and and i think
that
regardless of how good your fungicide
program is
you know under certain conditions your
grass isn't going to hold up
well and and it's especially true rich
uh
you know when you talk to steve rabadu
at wingfoot
he'll tell you the thing that he sweated
out the most was keeping the ruff alive
for a september u.s
open right keeping you know three inch
three and a half inch bluegrass we'll
get into this with the lawn guys
tomorrow a little bit more
but but even keeping power or kentucky
bluegrass alive
uh through the crap we're not just
talking about po annua but
you're trying to grow bluegrass on these
high-end joints in the summertime rich
that's no walk in the park brother
no oh oh no heck no you know
yeah i mean at least at least he knows
how to irrigate you know
in homes irrigation is all over the
place
well but let's get to this and let's
wrap up here we only got a few minutes
left and i want to get your word on this
root stuff
because as we prepare for it over the
next several weeks and
probably will cover this topic again uh
in the webinars
irrigation amount when you say execution
i never let any of you guys leave
without sort of
having a chat about how much water and
do you think guys water enough
and are there you know we know from
kearns's graduate students work that it
ain't getting very deep even in
well-designed sand-based systems with
not any layers in them
um i wonder what your thoughts are about
how effectively we irrigate these things
during our execution i
don't think we irrigate enough you know
and
and you know it depends on the water
solubility of the product
so that's a piece of information you
know thiophenate methyl
is way less water soluble than than uh
propagandazole
and in in dr clark's research you know
30 years ago
they were using 10 gallons of irrigation
water you know
you know it was two inch tall banner
kentucky bluegrass in those trials but
but uh you know uh uh you gotta you
gotta spray at least two gallons
and then i think guys ought to just do a
little experiments you know some citizen
science
where they run the heads and see how
much root zone gets wet
and then you get an idea of how much
water you have to apply to
to get that you know that moisture
through your
root zone exactly right
all right there we are hey carl we're
right on the number brother
uh questions or things uh before we wrap
it up
yeah no questions uh it's just it's so
interesting to hear you guys
talk about this stuff and and for rich
to pull out graphics from
a book that he probably read 10 years
ago and just be able to recite that it's
so interesting listening to
uh no questions but maybe i'll just get
everybody out of here on a note
um you know i'm writing down notes about
how intricate the timing of these
these programs whether you're it's
curative for foliar disease or
preventative for some of these root
pathogens
there's all these factors going into the
timing rich said timing matters
and i'll just make a note that you know
other ways to prevent preventive is also
as always couch to this kind of chemical
term pesticides
but other preventative things for
anthracnose bmps top dressing right
mowing mowing height um when we're
talking about
choosing uh turf resistant varieties
right that's something that
you know timing doesn't matter and that
sets you up for a long term
future so again couching this and kind
of reducing pesticide use
we heard rich talk about the importance
of those practices and and those are
evergreen right those continue to give
you benefits you don't have to worry
about the minutia all this stuff so
um with that thanks everybody for uh for
attending we got a couple
uh questions in here late but we'll get
to those uh maybe in next week's webinar
uh thanks everyone uh for attending
third episode this year cornell turf
show fastest 30 minutes in turf
for frank rossi for rich buckley i'm
carl scamenti thanks everybody we'll see
you
guys
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu